it's way easier to make friends if you
are going to see pre-existing friends
the way you have a bit of a sort of
chicken and egg situation is that if you
don't know anyone in the place that
you're visiting then you it's hard to
kind of get that social network off the
ground
um i've got a few friends who we've
spoken spoken to about this like digital
nomady type life who are like kind of
working in a traditional law slash
consulting such banking job here in
london the only people they know are the
people from university slash people
working in that job and to them the
thought of like making friends on the
internet just seems a bit bizarre and to
them like twitter is this thing that
gets that gives them the news and like
incendiary things that donald trump has
well tweeted in the past uh what is the
process of
making friends around the world look
like these days okay so maybe a good
place to start with this is is like
where do you actually start if you
literally are someone who has the
flexibility to try out the nomad
lifestyle um
what what does it look like to kind of
like meet
like where do you go in order to kind of
like meet people on the ground and i
think number one is co-working spaces so
co-working spaces can be a really really
good source of
social connections so
as well as physically like working in
the same space as others maybe going to
get a coffee and ending up chatting to
someone that kind of thing um there are
also a lot of like networking events or
just general events like whether it's
like morning yoga or kind of like salsa
classes or things like that like they
tend to be like community hubs so i
guess in the same way that if you were
to move to a new city as a remote worker
as in to relocate let's say from london
to paris you would be like okay how am i
gonna make new friends here
maybe and work i still think it's a
really big source of like new friends um
so yeah that would be number one it's
like co-working spaces super super
useful really great resources some folks
kind of say like oh i don't want to pay
for a co-working space i'd rather just
get accommodation with a table but it's
like okay but then you will be lonely
because you have to optimize for a whole
bunch of different things as a nomad not
just like affordability or whatever so i
think there are sort of different
benefits at different times another
thing i'd say is that like being part of
a remote team is a really good way to
have international connections so at
safety wing we have i think it's 120
employees across 70 countries
so if i had just joined our team and i
wanted to to kind of travel around the
world and not get too lonely i feel like
it's uh really easy to just be like okay
so who do i speak to a lot at work shall
i see if i can go and kind of visit them
and not necessarily like staying in
their house although some people very
kindly do offer that and that can be
kind of a nice intimate way to get to
know a place and to kind of be closer
with a colleague but literally just
going to the same city and so it's like
okay great so
i'm going to stay for three months and
once a week i'm gonna have in fact
london's a good example it's like okay
i'm gonna spend three months in london
and once a week i'm going to have lunch
with ali and that's kind of your
starting point
to then kind of build out more of a
social network okay yeah so i guess it
doesn't it doesn't seem as hard as i've
got like i'm kind of thinking in my head
because like yeah if i were to move to
i don't know a new city i didn't know
anyone i would do those things i'd be
like all right i need to actively take
charge of my own social life you know
set up the the hinge profile or whatever
look on meetup.com to see what's going
on look at anything anything local join
a local gym join local badminton club
all of all of the usual things that a
normal person would do to get to know
people i guess also applies to the
the digital nomad totally hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day